for the past
30 40 years
we've over indexed on individualism and
the finite mindset
you know almost all the reward
structures inside our companies reward
only individual performance and yet we
have to work together in teams we we're
not very good at team reward um
we also over indexed on the on
on a finite mindset um which i'm sure
we'll touch upon in a moment basically
the short term
um
and in so doing we've over the course of
years we've taken our eye off the ball
of the importance of culture and the
importance of leadership and the
importance of people yes a lot of
leaders give it lip service and talk
about it
but you know great culture is not giving
away free food
greek culture is how people feel when
they come to work um and you know what
we do there's a lot of evidence that for
example the the amount of time that
people spend on a job is getting shorter
and shorter uh and we've heard that
levied against entire generations you
know millennials they just don't stick
around well i would argue that that's
nothing to do with the generation it has
to do with the generation before it
that's leading them you know uh it's
it's nothing to do with young
generations at all which is if you give
people an environment where they feel
seen where they feel heard where they
feel understood when they feel
recognized as a human being they'll want
to stay there for for decades but when
we treat people like numbers or when we
expect people only and judge people only
by their ability to hit an arbitrary
number by an arbitrary date that weighs
on someone um and i'll give you i'll
give you a real life example
of of what that looks like and then and
then answer the converse uh uh you know
here's a fairly typical
scenario um somebody in a leadership
position walks into one of their uh
their teammate team members uh offices
for example and says your numbers are
down for the third quarter in a row
we've had this conversation before you
better get your numbers up in the fourth
quarter otherwise i don't know what's
going to happen you know that's kind of
normal it's kind of a familiar scenario
whether we've given that talk or been on
the receiving end of it
um what do you think that does for the
person the receiving end of it i mean
that is demoralizing
you're you've instilled fear in them
now let's add a little empathy because
that's what was missing from that answer
is empathy seeing that person as a human
being
you walk in their office and you say you
know your numbers are down for the third
quarter in a row we've had this
conversation before
are you okay i'm worried about you
what's going on
and that's what's missing which is we
need a lot more good leadership which
includes things like how to give and
receive feedback listening skills
empathy all of these we've just
forgotten to teach leaders how to lead